j'arrive en retard les go films
le décorateur alors philippe quand tu
vois les johnny est très fier de son
intérieur fini pratiquement j'adore
j'adore il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
changé
j'avais pas vu mon la table la cheminée
en croco là alors ça je n'ai jamais eu
besoin de la patte
non mais je vais pas faire la même chose
marc hinger toit léger il est beaucoup
plus rock'n'roll que je le suis ici
c'est pour ça le canafe 9 rigoles ou
quoi c'est qu'à l'horizon tectoy la
terre
j'entends ville histoire en échange
oubliés du bleu du rouge du noir quand
j'ai acheté la maison c'était une maison
qui était un peu un peu triste ça me
correspondait pas tout à fait au point
de vue décoration et puis elle est
longuement discuté avec philippe et puis
on a complètement changé toute la
décoration c'est un ami on avait sur les
colonnes et sur les murs
petit à petit on a aménagé tout ça et
puis ça commence à ressembler un peu
plus à ma personnalité
puis à celle de laëtitia aussi chez que
en étant quand même un peu le côté droit
commun
[Musique]
pour moi le los angeles est un petit peu
de détente vacances et en même temps au
travail parce que comme je je répète
avec le musicien ici quand je fais des
spectacles et en même temps j'enregistre
mes albums ici donc je mélange les deux
et puis moi ici ça me permet d'avoir mes
motos mais voiture pour moi c'est
l'idéal autres gars vous avez la cuisine
à la cuisine je n'ai pas vu mon visage
magnifique ou alors ça c'est une folie
douce j'adore ça c'est bon un truc pour
toi saint lô fisher price
elvis a mais j'avais pas vu ça va joli
ça c'est une photo unique si tout
paraissait elle devenue aussi bon à ce
genre de site chami dans la cuisine
et c'est parti pour une journée entre
amis et en eau trône
les petits bolides au look années 30
prendre repousser un prix pas la balle
tombe à altia avait bien sûr pas le mien
tu l'as vu toi oui d'accord avec ton en
dessous comme c'est mon cas que je me
perds geass allemagne